scorpion okay now maybe a storm pin
well I guess evolution is beats see that
similar ninja jump out I've got you [ __ ]
you and your ninja tips stop the jumping
away
stop jumping at me - you're back or
something yeah hey like that hey like
that you're getting better I'm getting
worse
stop
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't even know how to do this
[Music]
and you us oh [ __ ] look at the size of
this guy oh my god no no no [ __ ] you and
your handsome friends Adam oh geez oh my
god [ __ ] me get up get up
oh this guy is a [ __ ] man this needs
to be [ __ ] say hello to my little friend
oh oh dude how do you even do that
oh I cry don't you touch it absolutely
[Laughter]
who the target
you
stop shooting me you [ __ ] [ __ ] about
it
go to vet it come here
no jumping you want some of this [ __ ] no
slaps you like it here he's like furious
button mashing like a sewer in Falls oh
this game is rain
oh oh look at that boy look at that boy
oh how nice
[Music]
and it's in good old our baby